I'm a photojournalist typically based in
Istanbul and from Texas that I have to
be visiting my family in Houston and
this is what we're dealing with right
now I'm in about a foot of water it's
getting worse by the minute
and I'm about to evacuate my mother to
higher ground yeah they're expecting two
more feet of water at least so we'll see
and started to come in water is
literally seeping into our house as I
make this video it's at the doorstep
coming in so we're trying to get clocks
furniture anything that's valuable
jewelry down or up from ground level and
we're thinking about evacuating with her
three dogs - to a place that is a little
bit safer I'm sorry mom if I'm attached
so much
ah hold on to their bags and push the
rap there we go like that I'll carry one
of them okay we're gonna switch rats
when you get close to me waist deep
right now trying to get a higher dogs
there's one down there and my mom's got
her 19 year old dachshund in a trash bin
going against the current right now
it'll take about 45 minutes we're
walking yeah we can do it I walked I
walked to your house the other day
we're walking to a garage apartment
I'm on highway 610 one of Houston's
major highways that loops around the
city
there's people hitchhiking on the side
of the road if you can see them look
like they're in trouble luckily I got my
mom to safety she's in a neighbor's
house we were trying to wade over to
where I'm staying which is only about
less than a about 1/4 of a mile away and
she couldn't make it she's got she had
too much stuff and three dogs so I'm
going to go try to get my camera's now
after walking about quarter to half a
mile I finally reached dry land I got my
cameras now all my stuff is dry I'm
staying on the second story of the house
so luckily this house hasn't been
flooded yet and I'm about to go back in
to water to go check on my sister she
was about half a mile away so we'll see
though i'm literally two houses down for
my sister and chest-deep water and I
have to tell you this is the most
nervous I've ever been about dropping a
phone I've got my plastic bag on my
tiptoes now I think I've been about
three miles in the neighborhood Bel Air
the parameter I've walked about three
miles and this is the worst street where
my sister lives that's her house over
there right behind me right behind that
sign this is my sister's house round two
getting back to dry land
[Music]